it destroyed my life it took everything
away from me it took my hopes my dreams
everything he was everything to us
nobody helped me and nobody cared the
fact that this man is dead
a grandfather murdered on Mother's Day
our eight news now investigators
learning the police people uh think that
they are involved left one big clue
behind tonight we dig for answers as
this unsolved homicide nears the one
year mark here is a news now
investigator David Charles
he was a he was a real life Angel I've
never met nobody like him before Crystal
Anderson says she met James Wagner 20
years ago he was like a beam of energy
he was so positive let's put your shoes
on after two kids and two grandchildren
their lives would be changed forever
Anderson remembers Wagner a business
owner and a veteran saying this in the
days before his death he said they're
gonna kill me and I stayed home
he never said nothing
he hid everything for me that didn't
think was bad if he got into it with
somebody or something he did not want me
to know because you know the first thing
I was going to do was call the police
May 8th 2022 Mother's Day the 59 year
old is inside an apartment here on
Maryland Parkway near Charleston when
someone fires one bullet killing him
what makes this case so difficult to
solve we do not have any witnesses that
are willing to come up and tell us
exactly what happened Metro homicide
detective Lawrence Gilbert says
Witnesses saw two people running from
the apartment after The Gunshot but the
Trail Ends there short of that we have
got nothing there is this whoever shot
and killed Wagner was able to get inside
the building and to Wagner's apartment
door but they didn't go inside he had
things in his house that were of value
entry was never made into the house
you're going to rob somebody and and
shoot them per se
you would take something but nothing was
actually taken from the residents I
found that kind of peculiar do you think
people have talked about this and
they're just not coming forward yes I do
without much to go on detectives hope
the simple fact this unsolved murder
happened on Mother's Day will evoke some
hidden memory is it likely that the
person who killed James Wagner is still
in that area yes yes it is it is very
likely let's play your game now Anderson
is left caring for the children and
grandchildren she in Wagner share she's
working a minimum wage job trying to get
by while hoping to help find the person
who killed her best friend and caretaker
I had nobody to help me with my kids
nobody to get them to school nobody
they'll buy us food nobody to help us
with anything I have been struggling a
summer night I've never suffered in my
whole life like I have I lost everything
they took everything away from me when
they took James as for those two
suspects Witnesses say they saw a black
man in a light skin and woman they say
that woman had distinctive red hair the
pair then got into a car and drove off
after Wagner's murder that information
means something to you from Mother's Day
of last year give police a call I'm
David charns 8 News Now